>> Sean: JOE BIDEN’S BORDER
CRISIS IS WORSENING BY THE DAY,
FRANKLY BY THE HOUR AND WHAT WE
ARE SEEING PLAYING OUT ON THE
BORDER IS ENTIRELY
SELF-INFLICTED, ENTIRELY A
CREATION OF HIS OPEN BORDERS
AGENDA, JUST LOOK AT THIS, NOW
LEARNING TONIGHT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION REPORTEDLY HAS
ONLY EXPELLED 13% OF MIGRANT
FAMILIES IN THE LAST WEEK AND
ACCORDING TO AXIOS, THAT MEANS
JUST 13% OF NEARLY 13,000 FAMILY
MEMBERS ATTEMPTING TO CROSS THE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER ILLEGALLY
WILL RETURN TO MEXICO BETWEEN
MARCH 14TH AND MARCH 21ST AND
THAT’S UNDER TITLE 42.
THAT’S OPEN BORDERS PLAIN AND
SIMPLE AND BIDEN IN THE
DEMOCRATS DESTRUCTIVE AGENDA IS
ON FULL DISPLAY ALL ACROSS THE
BOARD AS THE BIDEN TEAM IS NOW
PLOTTING TO UNVEIL YET ANOTHER
RECKLESS SPENDING PACKAGE, THIS
ONE WITH A PRICE TAG OF
3 TRILLION MORE DOLLARS ON TOP
OF THE 2 TRILLION THEY JUST
SPENT AN THAT’S EXPECTED TO BE
PACKED WITH A LOT OF
GREEN NEW DEAL CLIMATE MEASURES
AND THAT’S NOT ALL BECAUSE THE
EFFORTS COULD ALSO TO GIVE D.C.
STATEHOOD APPEARS TO BE GAINING
SOME STEAM AMONG DEMOCRATS ON
CAPITOL HILL WHICH AGAIN WOULD
BE NOTHING MORE THAN A BLATANT
AND SHAMELESS POWER GRAB THE
STACK THE SENATE WITH TWO MORE
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS.
HERE WAS A REACTION TO ALL OF
THIS AND MUCH MORE,
SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
FOLLOWING THE LAWS THAT YOUR
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT PASSED ON
IMMIGRATION, NOW THEY WANT TO
BYPASS YOUR BRANCH AS IT COMES
TO THE ISSUE OF GUNS THAN THEY
WANT D.C. STATEHOOD IN
PUERTO RICO STATEHOOD, THEY
THINK THAT WILL GIVE THEM FOR
ADDITIONAL DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
IN PERPETUITY AND THAT MEANS A
MAJORITY IN PERPETUITY.
YOUR REACTION.
>> IT’S INSANE AT MULTIPLE
LEVELS BUT CONGRATULATIONS TO
SARA CARTER AND YOUR TEAM.
IF THIS IS PROVEN TO BE TRUE AND
I HAVE NO DOUBT IT IS, ALL I CAN
SAY -- LET ME TELL YOU THIS,
ACCORDING TO YOUR REPORTING IS
SUPPOSED TO HOLD 80 PEOPLE, THEY
WERE 694 CHILDREN IN POD THREE A
BEING MANAGED BY TWO BORDER
CONTROL AGENTS.
GOD BLESS THE BORDER PATROL,
GOD BLESS THE CUSTOM AGENTS WHO
WERE DEALING WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SHOW AT THE
BORDER.
I AM GOING DOWN WITH 18 SENATORS
FRIDAY AND IF I DENY THE ABILITY
TO LOOK INTO ANYPLACE I WANT TO
GO, WE ARE GOING TO SHUT THE
SENATE DOWN.
WHERE IS AOC, ELIZABETH WARREN,
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS WHO
BASICALLY PROTESTED OUTSIDE OF
THE FACILITY IN HOMESTEAD,
FLORIDA, DURING THE TRUMP YEARS
HOLDING MIGRANT CHILDREN?
HERE’S MY MESSAGE,
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS, WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT, GO AND LOOK AND SEE
WHAT YOU HAVE CAUSED BY POLICIES
THAT WILL NOT WORK, QUIT DENYING
THE OBVIOUS, THIS IS NOT A
CRISIS, IT’S BEYOND A CRISIS,
IT’S A NATIONAL SECURITY
DISASTER IN THE MAKING, INHUMANE
SITUATION CAUSED BY BAD POLICY,
IT WILL NEVER CHANGE,
PRESIDENT BIDEN, AND UNTIL YOU
TELL EVERYBODY TO GO HOME AND
STOP BRINGING PEOPLE INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
IF YOU’RE NOT WILLING TO DO
THOSE TWO THINGS, WE WILL HAVE A
MILLION PEOPLE AT OUR BORDER BY
JUNE.
>> Sean: I WISH I WAS WRONG.
I PREDICTED THEY WOULD IMPLEMENT
THE MOST RADICAL LEGISLATION IN
HISTORY, I TOLD THIS AUDIENCE
THEY WOULD TRY TO ELIMINATE THE
LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER.
GEORGE BIDEN SAID HE NOW
SUPPORTS THAT.
I TALKED ABOUT THEY WOULD TRY TO
PACK THE COURTS AND THEY NOW
HAVE A COMMISSION STUDYING THAT
VERY THING.
I MENTIONED D.C. IN PUERTO RICO
STATEHOOD AND THAT IS ALSO
HAPPENING.
I ALSO PREDICTED THEY WOULD RULE
BY EXECUTIVE FIAT, THEY WANT
OPEN BORDERS AND AMNESTY.
SO FAR, 4 FOR 4 AND 5 FOR 5 IF
YOU WANT TO ADD THEY DESTROY THE
ENERGY SECTOR.
>> RIGHT.
THIS IS BIG NEWS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE WHAT WOULD BE
HAPPENING TOMORROW MORNING IF WE
FOUND THESE EMAILS ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S WATCH?
CAN YOU IMAGINE THE NEWS
TOMORROW WHEN YOU HAD 694
CHILDREN IN A POD MEANT FOR 80
PEOPLE MANAGED BY TWO BORDER
PATROL AGENTS, CAN YOU IMAGINE
THE PROBLEMS WITH COVID WE ARE
EXPERIENCING AT THE BORDER?
14,000 UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN A
MONTH COMING BECAUSE THE FIRST
THING THEY DID WAS DECIDE TO
EXEMPT UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN
FROM TITLE 42 DEPORTATION.
HAVE A CHILD MAKES IT INTO
AMERICA, THEY WILL STAY IN
AMERICA AND WON’T BE SENT BACK.
THAT’S BEING ABOLISHED.
IF YOU GET TO AMERICA, THEY WILL
RELEASE YOU IN AMERICA.
THEY HAVE CREATED THIS PROBLEM
BECAUSE THEY CHANGE POLICIES.
WHERE ARE THE LIBERALS GOING TO
THE BORDER AND LOOKING AT THE
KIDS LIKE THEY DID WITH TRUMP?
ALL I CAN SAY IS I’M GOING DOWN
WITH 18 SENATORS AND IF THEY
DENY ME THE ABILITY TO GO WHERE
I WANT TO GO AND SEE WHAT I WANT
TO SEE, WE ARE GOING TO SHUT THE
SENATE DOWN.
>> Sean: YOU ARE GOING,
SENATOR TED CRUZ IS GOING, GOING
THIS FRIDAY, WE WILL BE THERE
WITH YOU AND OUR CAMERAS WILL BE
THERE AND I WANT TO ASK YOU
THIS -- I DON’T WANT TO HEAR ANY
MORE LECTURES ABOUT MASK WEARING
AND SOCIAL DISTANCING AFTER
LOOKING AT THESE VIDEOS, 900%
OVER CAPACITY HERE LITERALLY
SLEEPING ON TOP OF EACH OTHER
AND FRANKLY THOSE PLASTIC
CONTAINERS, THOSE PODS ARE THE
NEW KIDS IN CAGES AND MAYBE
BECAUSE I’VE ASKED AND I’VE BEEN
TRYING AND WE’VE HAD REPORTERS
TRY THEM I CAN YOU SEE IF MAYBE
YOU CAN GET INSIDE THE CARGO
SHIPPING CONTAINERS THAT THEY
ARE ALSO DUMPING KIDS IN THE
MOTHER ONE WITH A TINY WINDOW
WITH BARS ON IT?
I LIKE TO SEE WHAT THOSE
CONDITIONS LOOK LIKE.
>> I’D HATE TO BE THE GUY THAT
TOLD ME KNOW THAT IS NOT THE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS, THEY ARE
DOING A TERRIFIC JOB UNDER
TERRIBLE CIRCUMSTANCES.
PRESIDENT BIDEN NEEDS TO GET TO
THE BORDER ALONG WITH HIS
VICE PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW.
YOU NEED TO GO TO THE BORDER,
MR. PRESIDENT .
YOU NEED TO TAKE A GOOD NAP AND
GET TO THE BORDER.
>> Sean: HE HAS TO PREPARE
MOST OF THE WEEK FOR HIS BIG